gasteyger parole du monde je te dis bien
de ce que je veux faire quand j'étais
petit mon nom mon comédiens ses
comédiens que je voulais faire tu te
rappelles pas mais je dois faire comme
travail de m comment tu merci pour
qu'est ce que tu veux faire du théâtre
après ses rêves de gosse j'espère
travailler en binôme avec m clément
roméo et juliette pourquoi je fais
juliette mois telle quelle origine parce
que dieu merci ces africains sont
annoncés entier paniproblème au quai
valin à la doudoune lino et avenue
d'athènes
évidemment tu l'as vu par tu veux pas
qu'ils commencent à répéter au top
appuie quoi qu'est-ce que je suis
content parce que mamie c'est un peu
compliqué parce que tu crois jamais
n'est pas compliqué pour l'antillais l'a
pas ratée de maître autel enfin le
concours je suis content faut que je
bosse des cesu marie josé pérec mais
c'est possible mais tu pars à roméo mais
tu passes d'un montaigu mot d'ailleurs
attendu
photo
vous êtes viré tous les étudiants
mangent des comédiens mais c'est pas ce
qui se passe en banlieue on aime bien
enterrer nos rêves de gosses temps les
terrains vagues